（音樂）
大家好，我係香港嚟嘅 Florence
（掌聲）
咁呢就原來呢嗰台好光嘅
我唔係好睇到大家
噉呀大家睇到我啦
噉呢其實我呢就
喺香港做緊一個 Bakery 嘅
噉我好想帶我啲同事嚟嘅
就係佢哋
噉呀帶唔到佢哋嚟
噉呢我就帶咗一條片
喺條片裡邊呢有兩個同事
同大家打個招呼先
我叫 Vincent
合桃提子包、吞拿魚包
法式豬仔包、迷你芝士酥
我做嘅
（音樂）
黑芝麻合桃提子包
係啦
（音樂）
拍一拍中間
睇下，呢個搞掂啦
（音樂）
我係 Vicky 陳詩敏
我係敏敏呀
呢個月餅…月餅呀...
聖誕曲奇呀，仲有新年曲奇
有我嘅設計，我嘅作品啦
我畫花、畫咗樹葉、畫間屋、畫海
畫人、魚、蝦、蟹，仲有動物
完成，搞掂，Yeah!
（掌聲）
係啦。噉呢 Vincent 呢
其實佢 2008 年呢
就加入我哋嘅 bakery 啦
佢第一年就已經學識咗
點樣做提子鬆餅囉喎
佢媽媽就好開心嘅
因為佢就成日去買佢做嘅提子鬆餅
就送俾佢啲親戚同朋友
噉喺 2010 年呢我哋正式開一間地舖啦
噉我哋就想請 Vincent 做我哋嘅同事囉喎
點知佢媽媽呢就好猶疑
噉佢同我哋講
我其實冇諗過佢會做嘢㗎
佢只要啫係呢開開心心
輕輕鬆鬆噉樣生活呢
就已經好足夠架啦
噉呢學下烘焙就嚟當做興趣班架啫
佢唔駛咁辛苦嘅
噉但係最後呢佢都答應咗
噉呀俾佢試下啦
噉 Vincent 呢就一路試
其實一零年到而家已經四年呢
噉佢呢四年裡邊其實都冇停過
噉佢係每一個禮拜同我哋其他同事一樣
都係返足六日工
而每一日亦都係返足八個鐘
噉而家除咗識做鬆餅
佢識做麵包啦，你見到喺片裡邊
噉識做曲奇餅
噉呢一張相呢係我哋今年六月呢
去京都做一個短期嘅培訓
噉 Vincent 都被挑選咗同我哋一齊去嘅
噉呢張相係喺京都凱悅酒店
嗰個餅房裡邊影嘅
詩敏
我呢就其實好鍾意佢呢一張相
佢呀…你見到佢個嘴角
係呀啫係好溫柔同埋呢就好專注
不過如果你幾年前識得詩敏嘅話呢
其實你係唔會想像到
佢係而家咁樣樣嘅樣嘅
因為呢佢好大脾氣嘅
同埋呢佢係會喺嘅個工場裡邊呢
會好多情緒啦
噉喺佢以前工作嘅地方呢
其實佢試過同啲同事相處得唔係幾好呢
就有一次係爭啲傷到個同事嘅
噉跟住梗係冇工做啦
冇工做就返咗屋企等咗一輪
噉最後呢
佢就嚟咗我哋嘅 Bakery 裏邊做嘢
噉我哋嘅同事…
佢一嚟到呢
我哋啲同事呢就已經好鍾意佢
點解呢?
因為佢做嘢佢好大力嘅
（笑聲）
同埋呢佢係呀佢洗嘢好乾淨嘅
因為喺佢嘅眼裡邊
係唔可以容納一個污點嘅
噉所以呢我哋就好開心啦有佢幫手
噉但係呢其實佢喺情緒方面
依然都係起起伏伏
都有一啲脾氣啦
噉我哋同事就花咗好多心機
幫佢建立一個工作流程
因為對於一個自閉症嘅人嚟講呢
如果有一個穩定嘅工作流程呢
其實佢哋係會安心一啲嘅
噉之後呢就幾年佢都情緒好咗好多啦
噉佢媽媽亦都同我哋分享
佢喺屋企嘅脾氣都好咗好多
噉最近兩年呢就更加被發掘到
佢有個藝術天份
大家睇佢畫畫，果啲畫靚唔靚呀？
因為佢已經去上緊堂呢
喺我哋有一個藝術學院
就每個星期要去上三日堂嘅
噉喺個三日堂老師就發覺
其實佢好有潛質做一個全職嘅藝術家
噉但係佢除咗畫畫之外
佢依然堅持我係要返工嘅
佢有三日都係會返番嚟
我哋個工房裡邊返工
我哋好容易將人分類呀
即係 able 嘅人、disable 嘅人
噉 able 嘅人呢就應該係可以照顧自己
佢係可以做嘢
而 disable，或者我哋叫殘疾人士
佢哋係需要人哋照顧
但係事實上係唔係咁呢？
其實中間仲有好多唔同嘅人
噉我頭先介紹嘅 Vincent 同呀詩敏
就係其中嘅一啲例子啦
噉其實呢位敬琳都係其中一位
啱啱加入我哋嘅 Bakery
噉我哋嘅 Bakery 呢其實成立嘅目標呢
係希望可以有一個訓練嘅機會
俾到呢一班朋友
等佢哋呢係可以搵到自己嘅能力喺邊度
同埋呢最重要
係搵到一份自己鍾意嘅工作
噉通過工作呢佢係可以同個社會接觸到
我哋 Bakery 呢就唔係一個慈善事業嚟嘅
我哋都係一盤生意
我哋都要自負盈虧
噉呢就…
所以呢我哋同普通嘅 Bakery 一樣呢
我哋係要做曲奇餅
成日諗下點樣可以
賣多啲曲奇餅呢去賺錢
但係除咗賺錢之外呢，我哋有兩個堅持
第一個堅持呢就係
我哋以同事嘅能力為本啦
點樣為之以同事能力為本呢？
我舉啲例子
大家有冇諗過我哋點解做 Bakery？
或者有冇人做過 Bakery?
頭先好似有位同事話俾我聽
佢以前做麵包㗎
噉可能冇做過 Bakery
但可能都你都做過一啲烘焙嘢
喺屋企做過曲奇餅、麵包蛋糕
噉我哋點解揀 Bakery 呢？
因為喺個 Bakery 裡邊個工序呢
佢係好多同埋好細碎嘅
噉除咗生產個部分
可以切割好多唔同嘅工作
佢仲有周邊嘅嘢啦
佢可以有清潔、包裝、送貨、銷售
有好多唔同嘅崗位
其實唔同能力嘅朋友呢佢都會有機會
喺呢度搵到佢自己嘅位置
我哋做好多曲奇餅架
因為…
我諗比麵包多好多
噉呢因為麵包呢
其實係一個好高深嘅學問嚟架
呢個我做咗 Bakery 之後我先知道嘅
噉而蛋糕甜品呢佢要求個技巧呢
係好高同埋要好準確
亦都要好認真
即係好準確嘅，好高嘅技術
噉呢啲呢其實呢聽落去都知道
唔會係我哋同事個強項
噉曲奇餅有咩唔同呢?
曲奇餅佢都需要一啲標準化嘅過程
但係呢，呢啲工序
我哋可以用一啲工具去輔助
譬如我哋會用磅啦
佢可以去秤嗰啲麵團啦
同埋曲奇餅如果做出嚟個個形狀唔同
我諗大家都接受到，係嗎？
因為佢係手工做架嘛
噉所以我哋呢就主力做好多曲奇嘅
噉而曲奇裡邊呢
有啲朋友就留意到
點解你咁多圓形嘅曲奇餅呢？
圓形嘅曲奇餅係點做嘅呢？
嗱。呢度有三種
呢三種係我哋王牌產品嚟架
雖然今日唔應該賣廣告
（觀眾：好好味呀！）
好好味，係呀，多謝 Agnes
圓形嘅曲奇餅呢
係我哋打咗一個大麵糰之後呢
我哋就去分啦，就去秤佢啦
呢三種
我哋都係每一粒都係 17 個 gram
噉於是有同事呢佢就負責
喺個磅上邊呢就去秤 17 個 gram
然後秤完之後呢就搓圓佢
真係擺喺手搓圓佢
搓圓佢之後擺喺個焗盤上邊
你輕輕噤下佢，噉就其實已經做咗
容唔容易呀？
其實冇做過烘焙嘅人呢
佢哋一嚟到我哋 Bakery 呢
佢都可以參與到啫係呢個工作
噉所以呢我哋有陣時
去諗新產品嘅時候呢
都要諗下佢嘅形狀係點樣樣
呢個包裝嘅罐
就今年我哋聖誕
會主力係賣緊一個咁樣樣嘅包裝啦
噉因為我哋覺得嗰個曲奇餅本身呢
係有個訊息喺度
但係個包裝當然都好緊要啦
噉我哋會搵我哋自己嘅
一啲我哋復康中心裡邊嘅院友
同埋好似敏敏咁，咁有天份嘅人呢
噉佢哋創作咗好多嘢
噉我哋喺佢裡邊呢就搵佢哋嘅畫作
就做一個咁樣樣嘅包裝
我哋希望喺嗰個曲奇呢
佢作為一個禮品呢
佢由內以外
佢都傳遞緊一個好一致嘅訊息
同埋都有唔同能力嘅朋友參與
係啦
噉呢，呢個係我哋小小發展啦
因為我哋一零年開始
其實過去四年呢就由一間鋪開咗
到而家開緊第七間
啱啱喺大圍有個工場
噉同埋同事呢
我哋由最初十四位同事呢
到今日我哋有六十位同事
噉唔係淨係只做 Bakery 啦
你見到有 Cafe 啦
所以大家嚟香港呢
係可以去我哋嘅 Cafe，喺金鐘架啫
噉呢就，亦都有…我哋亦都有做到會啦
同埋一啲曲奇嘅零售
噉我諗喺一個啫咁樣樣嘅
發展過程裡邊呢
其實我哋好重要諗緊一樣嘢都係
即返返去我頭先講嗰個堅持
究竟呢啲嘢係唔係我哋同事做到囉
噉同埋會唔會係可以發揮到佢哋嘅能力
噉所以呢個係…亦都係我哋未來…
即繼續去發展我哋業務嘅
一個好重要嘅一個考慮
噉第二個堅持呢就係 Collaborations
我哋要多啲同唔同嘅人合作
因為呢我哋好想去 involve 多啲人
喺我哋成個運作裡邊
同埋因為喺唔同人身上
我哋都會學到嘢啦
噉我哋同乜人合作呢？
首先自己嘅團隊裡邊要好合作啦
團隊呢，我哋成日講
頭先…
我嘅題目叫做：不同能力，同一熱愛
要建立一個不同能力嘅團隊呢
其實有啲難度嘅
噉我哋最初開個 Bakery 嘅時候呢
因為有啲同事都係外邊請返嚟架啦
佢哋好快會冇咗耐性
點解要成日都教架，點解教極都唔識架
或者教完之後第二日
好似重新又要嚟過呀，噉樣
噉有啲同事係咁
噉有一啲同事呢佢就會係︰
哎！佢哋其實應該學唔到架啦
不如我做埋佢果份，快啲做完去算數啦
又或者係好危險啊呢個
可能攞把刀佢都會覺得好危險
咁佢就唔會去俾佢去做嘅
噉但係呢就…我諗呢兩樣嘢
都唔係我哋想見到嗰個情況
噉點樣喺一個信任
同埋喺一個適當支援中間
我哋攞個平衡呢？
噉呢一樣係要花啲心機囉
而家我哋會定期
做好多員工嘅培訓同埋好多內部嘅溝通
噉我哋希望呢係可以慢慢建立到
有我哋自己一個團隊裡邊嘅文化
噉新嚟嘅同事而家相對地係
比較容易啲去 Tune in 到嗰個工作嘅
顧客好緊要啦，因為做生意呀嘛
顧客呢其實係…即除咗去幫襯我哋
我哋有收入之外呢
其實顧客對我哋嚟講嗰個意義好大嘅
因為顧客其實係陌生人嚟嘅
對於我哋嘅同事嚟講係陌生人嚟嘅
噉但係喺嗰個過程
佢嚟幫襯買嘢或者買我哋嘅產品
呢個過程呢其實產生咗一個互動呀
啫我哋同事呢
可以喺一個交易嘅過程中呢
可以接觸到好多唔同嘅人
噉我哋覺得呢一個好自然嘅互動呢
係幫我哋同事呢去融入社會呢
係一個好大嘅意義嚟架
義工對 iBakery 都係好緊要
因為我哋而家都有好多固定嘅義工啦
佢哋會固定嚟幫我哋手啦
有啲義工佢哋係會嚟幫我哋做運作嘅
譬如餐廳，我哋最忙碌嘅時候
會有人嚟幫手做樓面嘅工作啦
噉我哋 Bakery 好忙嘅時候
亦都有人嚟幫我哋手做曲奇
噉但係呢亦都有一啲唔同行業嘅人啦
唔同專業嘅人啦
呢一張相裡邊佢哋攞獎啦
因為佢哋係我哋啲 advisers
就幫我哋出謀獻策
就幫我哋一齊諗下我哋嘅生意
究竟點樣可以做好啲
噉義工除咗佢哋貢獻咗
時間、知識之外呢
我哋覺得最能夠得益嘅係可以通過佢哋
我哋同各行各業嘅人可以接觸到
有啲人呢除咗買我哋嘅產品呢
佢哋好鍾意嚟了解我哋做啲乜嘢
尤其是學生
噉呢過去我哋係接待過好多唔同嘅學生
大學、中學、小學
本地嘅、外地嘅、國內嘅
其實都有好多
馬來西亞好似未有
（笑聲）
希望日後有啦
噉呀…
有陣時係佢哋嚟啦，好多時候佢哋嚟啦
有陣時候係我哋出去做一啲分享
或者去學校嗰度做一啲分享啦
噉同埋舊年我哋同香港大學
合作寫咗一個 Case 啦
噉呢個 Case 已經成爲咗
佢哋商學院裡邊一個教材啦
噉坦白講做呢啲嘢呢
唔會即時幫到我哋生意好多
噉但係我哋覺得
如果喺一個年青人嘅心裡邊
我哋可以留下一個種子
呢個種子呢就係等佢哋知道
呢個世界上做生意
唔係一定淨係掛住賺錢啦
噉我哋覺得呢一樣嘢係好有意義嘅
噉所以呢我哋都會繼續做
呢張相都係一樣啦
喺頭先我哋喺今年六月嘅時候
喺京都凱悅酒店裡邊影嘅
我哋同凱悅酒店嘅合作呢
係佢哋俾咗一個 Recipe
就係京都抹茶曲奇
噉在座唔知有冇人試過啦
噉 Agnes 一定試過啦
（超好食呀！）
呀係。多謝多謝！
（有米芝蓮水準）
係多謝多謝！
係啦，美食家講，我哋一定要信佢啦
（笑聲、掌聲）
係呀，可以做出
一個咁嘅米芝蓮水準嘅曲奇呢
我哋好開心，因為…
（有三星）
三星呀，係嗎，係呀
有四星…如果有四星就攞四星呀
噉呢。固然之我哋係學到嘢啦
我哋又攞到個 Recipe，又學咗個技術
因為 Yasuda 生
呢一位佢哋嘅 Head chef
就唔單止我哋過過去
佢嚟過香港呀 train 過我哋同事一次
噉嚟緊十二月頭佢會嚟多一次
教我哋做另外一啲嘅產品
噉我哋得益
但係有一日呢就酒店嘅總經理呢
Yokoyama 生就同我講
佢話︰我真係要好多謝你哋
噉我問點解呢？
唔係應該我多謝你
噉你多謝我乜嘢呢？
噉佢話佢哋個團隊呢
同我哋嘅同事合作嘅時候好興奮
因為呢佢哋嘅同事覺得自己識得嘅嘢
可以用係一個咁有意義嘅途徑裡邊呢
佢哋覺得好開心
同埋呢同我哋一齊呢
就我哋嘅活力似乎都沾染咗佢哋
因為大家都知道
日本人係比較嚴肅一啲嘅
噉佢哋喺個餅房裡邊工作呢
原來係真係一粒聲都冇架
噉我哋當日去到呢個京都酒店嘅時候呢
突然之間我都有陣時覺得
好嘈呀我哋，我哋
噉但係原來佢哋都係即覺得好開心嘅
噉我諗喺呢一個合作呢
我自己學到嘅呢就係
要一個合作關係可以持久呢
其實係要做到一個 Win win 嘅 Exchange
即我唔係淨係去攞人哋啲嘢
我哋都有啲嘢要俾返人哋嘅
媒體呢絕對係我哋嘅好朋友啦
噉喺香港呢個媒體係好支持社會企業嘅
噉當然 Agnes 又係其中一位啦
噉過去幾年呢我哋建立咗
一個好好嘅媒體嘅網絡呀
噉每次我哋有節日產品
嚟緊聖誕，我又要啦
噉呢我哋就會請佢哋幫手去宣傳推廣
噉但係呢…
在座應該有做媒體嘅朋友呵？
係嗎？有呀呵？
媒體嘅朋友呢就唔係咁簡單嘅
你唔係叫佢寫佢就會寫嘅
噉同埋呢佢就…
佢就算好 buy 你嗰個 mission
佢寫完一次之後，你叫佢再寫
你今次究竟有咩新嘢呀究竟？係咪？
你如果冇新嘢嘅話，我點幫你寫呀？
噉所以喺佢哋鞭策底下呢
其實我哋都知道
自己要保持嗰個新鮮感呀
同埋呢就每一次呢我哋去諗一個宣傳
因為節日產品都係我哋啫係叫
「食粥食飯睇佢」
即係嚟緊啲聖誕、新年
噉呢我哋就要去諗點樣樣
個 angle 喺邊度，點樣去介紹
噉所以媒體絕對係我哋嘅好朋友啦
噉喺咁多篇報道裡邊呢
我好鍾意呢一個嘅
噉係記者陳曉蕾同我哋做嘅一個專訪
噉我用佢嚟做一個總結
因為裡邊佢講到
世界其實係一幅大拼圖
每個人都有自己嘅顏色
喺適當嘅位置呢就盡情發揮，自然漂亮
我相信呢我哋嘅同事呢
都喺我哋嘅 Bakery 裡邊呢
搵到自己果個位置
噉而我哋嘅 Bakery 呢
亦都喺呢個社會上
搵到我哋自己嘅位置嘅
我哋係會好踏實噉樣去做啦 bit by bit
我哋會好用心噉樣去做啦
做好每一個產品啦
bite by bite，每一個 bite 都咁好味嘅
噉我哋想用呢一個
a little bite different
就去提醒大家
其實我哋嘅社會上面都係需要平等機會
同埋對等尊重
多謝
（掌聲）